what's up guys today we're gonna get you
and look at the Asus Strix are OGG to be
7te gaming let's jump right in on the
front of the box you're greeted with the
motherboard picture and good logo of the
Republic of the gamers and titled up the
another board on the bottom there's a
logo tab over here and few barcodes on
the right side same thing on top there's
some different languages same thing on
the back there's lots of cool
specification such like expansion slots
chipset better stuff extra features
so the motherboard there's a simple
little flap right here that you just
come straight out and the cool whole
side comes out and once you got that
open first give me with walk up to
Republic
[Music]
Wi-Fi adapter
right after that find some underwear
itself
[Music]
that's what's inside the box let's take
a look at all the tortillas
so sorry from atop the motherboard here
has eight pin power cable for the CPU
and then it has two fan controllers
right there before DIMM slots another
fan controller right there
RGB header right there the 24 pin
motherboard cable and moving down here's
the mx2 slot right here and there's two
more fan controllers and one of them is
a OH
pump dedicates right there there's a few
PCI you export Express Lanes
and here's a USB 3.1 port front and
after you work our way down to
I use these people in home front your
header and
connectors right here
on the bottom there is a USB 2.0 there's
three USB 2.0 kind of anchors and a USB
3.0
there's another
and controller is about to break in
action
[Music]
and then there's the front panel
connectors like the audio jack if the
power button the reset button all that
stuff there's not that extension fan
controller here so if you buy a sis's
there a fan extender you can actually
add many more fans on to this there's
two more
RGB headers that's pretty much it for
all the ports on the front of the
motherboard on the back I of this
motherboard you can find force for the
u.s. the Bluetooth and Wi-Fi adapter
easy type-c supports DVI port the
display port HDMI port if you use the
characters give it Ethernet port and
audio get back all the circuitry alright
[Music]
now we got the multiple out of the way
and all the features at an S let's see
what else comes along so here as I said
before here is the Bluetooth and Wi-Fi
adapter here just connects to the top
two ports under the motherboard on the
back
so let's see well see this box you take
this thing out you actually have nice
manual very long Daniel very into some
stickers a DVD and a cable model code
I'm not gonna be using this so whoever's
able to do this first opinions there's
some information and some more stickers
finally on the very bottom there's four
SATA cables 90 degrees and straight to
90 degrees two minutes two straights is
an SLI bridge
there's some 3d mouse right here all
these cable ties the CPU cover some
screws more screws and some more zip
ties and the fan extensive view and
finally here is the i/o shield and I'll
enjoy well guys that's it for the asus
motherboard boxes here the guys wanna
learn more details like how the supreme
FX surround sound waves
more drivers and overclocking and how
the BIOS will make sure to check out my
full review we should be linked down in
the description
[Music]